un lieu et une date emblématique 57 ans
jour pour jour après le discours de
martin luther king sur son rêve
d'égalité entre tous les américains
des milliers de personnes ont à nouveau
défilé devant le lincoln memorial de
washington à la tribune
la petite fille du pasteur assure que la
vision de son grand père est toujours
d'actualité
moins d'un an avant son assassinat
mon grand père avait prédit ce moment
précis il disait que nous entrions dans
une nouvelle phase de la lutte
la première phase était celle des droits
civils et la nouvelle phase est celle de
la véritable égalité au discours qui
exalte la foule des manifestants au
coeur de leurs revendications la fin des
inégalités et du racisme systémique qui
gangrènent la société américaine c'est
exaltant d'avoir tout le monde réuni ici
autour d'une même cause et de défiler
pour la justice pour la paix et de dire
les noms de ceux qui ont perdu la vie
c'est formidable et je suis juste
heureuse d'en faire partie je suis juste
un parmi des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont là pour dire
blacklight naters je suis content de
constater qu'il n'ya pas que des noirs
qui sont là vous avez des personnes de
toutes les couleurs de toutes
nationalités et c'est vraiment beau
cette manifestation survient après une
nouvelle semaine de tensions raciales
aux états unis
deux manifestants ont été abattus à
kenosha dans l'état du wisconsin par un
adolescent qui avaient répondu à l'appel
de constituer une milice contre les
émeutiers à l'origine des affrontements
l'interpellation très violente de jack
black un père de famille de 29 ans il a
été atteint par cette balle dans le dos
tiré à bout portant par un policier
blanc
trois mois après la mort tragique de
georges flood un contexte qui ne fait
pourtant pas vaciller le président
américain en pleine campagne pour sa
réélection
au lendemain de sa nomination officielle
comme candidat des républicains
donald trump a accusé les manifestants
de se comporter comme des voyous
c'est dingue c'est dingue
vous avez vu ça hier à washington c'est
une honte
c'est une honte que ces gens
représentent les états unis
c'est une honte fidèle à sa ligne de
conduite le locataire de la maison
blanche espère ainsi profiter de ce
contexte pour galvaniser son électorat
face aux manifestations qui se
poursuivent chaque nuit dans la ville de
kenosha 250 soldats de la garde
nationale ont été déployés et un
couvre-feu a été instauré